Simmons on the take Kevin's explosive to
the basket [ __ ] all night long Tyler
Johnson has is taking the shots he
watched where he wants to get a minute
this time sevens on the receiving end
tall
tough shot Whitehead really extended on
that does he see dragons taking right
back to the racket beautiful spin move
so Johnson this is the three out of pile
the board Johnson goes to the hole take
it on in beat no followed by BAM on a
bio then Johnson goes in draws and beat
over and bio comes in from the top of
the basketball i.q
not a great shooter but does everything
else really well for their Celtic team
Simmons backing down Wednesday taken in
the post under two and a half to go
Olynyk with four on the shot clock
trying to find someone Winslow is there
for three and it's going to go a
friendly bounce for justice Winslow no
oh he's got little guy on him
JoEllen bead all the way
that draaga Jonathan he wanted that ball
still a work-in-progress Connells done
an excellent job in that backup role and
then B that was easy
the two six minutes to go in regulation
weighed on the given go and the reverse
is good Tyler Johnson with the dish but
a long drought between made baskets
Redick took three big one
[Applause]
the Philadelphia 76ers ready to move on
into the Eastern Conference semifinals
going to expire here
[Music]